Guten morgen tim.
Du der boris johnson der ist für mich gerade das beste pferd im stall du erinnerst dich an unsere fünf euro wetter du kannst da schon mal den fünfer bügeln ich will dann fabrik neuen frischen gut riechen in firma.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik ausgabe nummer drei komma eins vier eins fünf neun zwo sechs fünf drei fünf neun.
Dreihundert vierzehn sendungen haben werden wir jetzt zusammen gehabt haben so wie denn jetzt hier irgendwann auch ein ende finden.
Das war eine runde sache.
Müssen wir erstmal müssen wir erstmal sehr runde sache genau erstmal anfang finden fünfer witze haben ja ja.
Ich habe gesagt brexit was habe ich gewettet brexit kommt ne.
Ja ich habe gesagt kommt nicht.
Zur wahrheit haben oder nicht haben werden wir sehen.
Ich halte ich halte allerdings auch meine.
Ich find's halt schade eigentlich fast wenn das wenn das irgendwann vorbei sein sollte weil das irgendwie so.
Es wird einfach nie geklärt werden dann müsst ihr den vielleicht irgendwann mal so.
Zwölf jahre,
wir werden niemals einen presse doch doch nächstes monat nächsten monat eröffnen wir den brexit ach nee stellt sich stellt sich raus die entgiftung wir haben noch nicht entlüfter in den berg wird wir müssen noch,
wir verschieben den nochmal.
Also wenn dann irgendwann das internationale die internationale sinus welle der mal wieder nach oben geht dann würde ich sagen da ist also die deadline also wenn es bis dahin nicht geschafft haben dann dann dann dann dann gilt das auch irgendwie und dann,
kannst du dir überlegen ich brauche nicht gebügelt mir reicht einfach so ein stick normale digitale überweisung apple pay kannst dann zahlen.
Ich bin ja total unromantisch hauptsache hauptsache geld hauptsache ordentliche hauptsache korrekt gebucht.
Aber also ich würde das interessanter machen ich hatte es ja sollte ich verlieren überweisen ich dir das auch in pfund.
So kommst du mir nicht davon dass es ja da nichts mehr wert wobei dann steigt der preis,
du weißt fünf pfund ich kann mir das aussuchen.
Nee nee nee ich suche mir das aus.
Tja brexit
eigentlich müsste man mal wieder zusammen fegen was eigentlich passiert ist es wird allerdings echt wirklich richtig unübersichtlich und spannend also der nächste monat ist auf jeden fall wieder einmal der höhepunkt von allem.
Kannst du denn überhaupt noch folgen.
Den brexit.
Dem ganzen gedöns drumherum.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht also ich habe ich habe mir nur irgendwie mal glaube ich letztes mal schon drüber gesprochen diese diesen den johnson da im house of comments wieder angeschaut,
was für ein niveau dass es so bedauerlich was für ein niveau also.
Jeder ist auch wirklich schlecht ich meine da hatte ich weiß nicht was du jetzt genau gesehen hast äh.
Das ist auch eigentlich relativ egal das niveau ist bei dem ja stabil.
Ja aber es gab schon so ein paar highlights also ich meine wie alter dann der meinung war das andenken an die von einem,
englischen nationalisten umgebracht den parlaments angehörigen würde am besten dadurch gesichert werden dass man den den brexit durchzieht,
gegen den sie war das ist dann schon echt der vorläufige tiefpunkt aber wie bei trump denke ich mal wird auch seine weitere karriere die hoffentlich nicht mehr so lange läuft,
relativ oft noch weitere tiefen erreichen also es wird nicht mehr besser werden.
Was habe ich wasser was fand ich den den tiefpunkt ich muss jetzt überlegen,
der typ ist einfach ein tiefpunkt also ich meine man kann ja von mir aus die meinung vertreten großbritannien müsse aus der eu aussteigen.
Das ist jetzt erstmal die meinung kann man ja vertreten aber es wäre schon echt super wenn das irgendwie ein bisschen sinnvoller,
von staaten gehen würde und dann irgendwie genau ja so mein mein lieblingstier punkt war,
er als er hat ja das parlament außer kraft setzen wollen indem er die queen irgendwie von,
wie viele sagen nicht ganz so den tatsachen entsprechende.
Tatsachen gestellt hat und das wurde ihm ja vom,
vom höchsten gericht des landes vom supreme kassiert deswegen saß er da überhaupt erst mal wieder ja,
ich glaub dieser dieses gericht ist auch mit zwölf richterin besetzt.
Elf also in dem fall waren.
Und dann wird ihm wird er halt gefragt wie er sich da.
Wir denn damit jetzt umgeht dass er da der verfassung irgendwie wieder ne das urteil wurde vom verfassungsgericht und dann sagt er ja das wird jetzt respektvolle eine andere juristische auffassung haben und denkst so,
alter das ist der supreme ja das mag sehr gut sein dass du eine andere auffassung hast aber die steht nicht in konkurrenz
zudem so man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen okay ich habe die verfassungsgemäß brauchen die verfassung gebrochen laut,
verfassungsgericht aber hey respekt vor ne also feelings hier ne,
so da kann man auch einfach unterschiedliche meinung sein das finde ich eigentlich auch mal ganz geil das werde ich demnächst wenn ich irgendwann mal vor gericht irgendwie ein urteil habe was mir nicht gefällt würde ich auch sagen ja okay aber das jetzt auch irgendwie nur so.
Ihre meinung.
Fuck.
Ja ja.
Exactly dass das das ist das ding ne ich meine das hat natürlich,
ist schon ein ein interessantes playback was hier abgespielt wird es ja auch nicht neue wird ja auch von der mail und anderen und anderen,
terror blättern entsprechend begleitet und das gab es ja auch schon bei der ersten abstimmung des supreme cord wo sie halt gesagt haben hier das parlament muss entscheiden kann damit kann ich alleine aus europa austreten das er ursprünglich vorhatten
da kam es ja dann auch gleich so mit hier auf the people und so weiter also nur die richter.
Ja natürlich das wissen wir ja dass.
So genau diese in diese kategorie spielt das natürlich auch mit rein letzten endes geht's halt über trump nur darum die basis ist halt einfach deine deine leuten um die teilen und herrschen,
und das ist halt das üble spiel was hier gerade gespielt wird,
da fang als abgesehen müssen sie sich natürlich trotzdem im rahmen immer noch im rahmen der gesetzmäßigkeiten bewegen.
Und äh da ist so einiges passiert so also ich denke mal dieser oktober das wird jetzt.
Der oktober der entscheidende oktober.
Dieser also ob es der entscheidende oktober ist nicht aber in diesem oktober könnte sich halt eine ganze menge entscheiden was mal so und danach,
sieht's jetzt aus weil letzten endes steht halt dieses datum an einunddreißigster oktober halloween soll halt,
mal wieder der brexit automatisch zum zugekommen und obwohl es halt eine riesige mehrheit,
in im parlament gibt und generell in europa natürlich das not dir 'ne schlechte idee ist droht es erstmal.
Und jetzt wird der johnson wieder das parlament aussetzen ne.
Das ist jetzt die neueste ankündigung dass sie das nächsten dienstag tun wollen,
ob sie es dann tun werden wird man sehen aber ich gehe mal davon aus ja das ist aber dann eben nicht in fünf wochen ausschalten sondern eben nur diese woche die als generell als angemessen gilt,
so oder so geht es natürlich darum hier zeit vom tisch zu nehmen um einfach den parlament möglichst wenig gelegenheiten zu geben in irgendeiner form weitere kluge schacht züge zu machen,
heißt aber auch nächsten montag wird auf jeden fall nochmal abgestimmt werden,
also nicht nicht abgestimmt über irgendwas abgestimmt aber es gibt sozusagen eine parlamentarische sitzung wo theoretisch auch eine option gezogen werden könnte ob diese option gezogen wird ist,
fraglich also es gibt ja verschiedene auf dem tisch.
Generell ist es halt so man will ihnen halt irgendwie man es gibt eine mehrheit im parlament die will not die verhindern,
ganz klar ist die ist da nur man hat keine einigung darüber wie man das am besten tun wollen,
würde was auf jeden fall eine option ist die sogenannte world of confidence.
Das ist das vertrauen.
Misstrauensvotum gegenüber dem premierminister was dann durchkommen würde dass es gar nicht so sehr.
Das thema die frage ist nur was passiert danach weil danach kannst du halt.
Musste ja bisher premierminister zurücktreten das würde er dann wahrscheinlich auch erstmal nicht tun da gibt's so diverse also ihr könnt ihr das so theoretisch alles auch noch wirklich komplett,
aussetzen und,
es gibt aber dann eben eine höhere wahrscheinlichkeit dass es dazu kommt dass eben ein vorläufige premierminister eingesetzt wird das wäre eine maßnahme die hätte man schon vor einiger zeit ziehen können wäre wahrscheinlich auch geschehen.
Wenn es halt nicht in form von diesem jerry kommen also,
leber partei so eine toxische weitere toxische person gibt die halt in dem ganzen lager der,
no no dealer und vor allem auch der rainer also die eigentlich generell mit brexit kurz prozess machen wollen einfach als,
weil auch so als extremisten aus der linken ecke gilt ja der mag halt die eu aus anderen gründen nicht.
Würde halt auch ganz gerne mal ordentlich sein sozialismus ideen,
nachhängen und in england sozusagen von der linken seite her aufräumen wo ihm dann eben die aus seiner position liberal neoliberale agenda der eu auch nicht in den kram passt dass das ist halt das problem,
warum es bisher eigentlich überhaupt noch keinen nennenswerten widerstand gab weil eben auf der linken seite uni alles in ordnung,
das heißt am ende denke ich würden sie sich auf was einigen aber wer da quasi gewinnt mit welchem deal das ist noch komplett offen.
Derzeit siehst du also so aus als ob es auch diese wut auf null konferenz erstmal nicht geben wird oder die wahrscheinlichkeit ist geringer.
Letzten endes wenn diese provokation phase also dieses parlaments pause dann ausgesetzt ist dann haben wir den vierzehnten oktober,
dann sitzt halt am siebzehnten oktober,
die eu zusammen und wollte halt eigentlich mal final beschließen was denn jetzt sache ist man wartet eigentlich die ganze zeit was geht,
und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es halt ein einen neuen deal gibt die es halt komplett ausgeschlossen und man kann auch davon ausgehen dass boris johnson überhaupt gar kein interesse daran hat,
er redet halt viel hat jetzt wieder neuen vorschlag gemacht wieder irgendwas halb gab es mit ja bitte kein back stop und wir machen mal hier und da irgendwelche kontrollen probleme ist alles was sie da vorschlagen widerspricht halt zutiefst dem,
karfreitag abkommen und von daher.
Wird das alles nicht stattfinden und es wird auch keine abstimmung selbst selbst wenn es eine einigung gäbe über einen neuen deal würde eine solche abstimmung.
Im parlament niemals gewinnen erstens weil sie keine keine zeit war dass das große diskutieren und zweitens geht jeder davon aus dass selbst,
ist ein neue ideal gäbe mit der eu der zur abstimmung gebracht wird,
das parlament sagen würde ja okay dann machen wir halt das was schon an sich sehr unwahrscheinlich ist sie werden es allein schon deshalb nicht tun weil alle davon ausgehen dass boris johnson danach,
einfach nur die gelegenheit ergreifen würde nichts zu tun weil er dann nicht mehr gezwungen wäre um eine erweiterung zu betteln wie es derzeit noch ist.
Vor dieser letzten provokation hat nämlich das parlament diesen sogenannten ben act beschlossen und dieser ben act verpflichtet den premierminister die eu um eine verlängerung zu bitten wenn am neunzehnten oktober noch kein neuer deal da ist,
würde also ein neuer deal beschlossen werden im parlament würde das nicht mehr gelten und dann würde es einfach nur aussetzen woche irgendwie nach mallorca fahren und sagen ach ist doch schön jetzt haben wir hier notiert automatisch nichts passiert,
deswegen wird es halt einfach zu einer abstimmung im parlament auf gar keinen fall kommen also zumindest zu keiner erfolgreichen und letzten endes,
wird sich alles darüber entscheiden entweder gibt es noch 'ne wut auf noch konferenz und es wird ein anderer premierminister eingesetzt der dann halt diese extension macht,
oder läuft's halt jetzt darauf hinaus dass nach dieser provokation gibt's dann queen speed,
und dann wird ja sozusagen das neue regierungsprogramm vorgestellt das ist ja diese,
provokation heißt ja danach gibt's eine neue parlamente,
session so hier haben wir sozusagen einen neuen durchlauf im parlament dann gibt's diese queens beach und damit wirst du sagen das regierungsprogramm vorgestellt das muss ja dann angenommen werden,
und das wird dann wahrscheinlich abgelehnt werden und dann spätestens müsse es eigentlich mit johnson auch vorbei sein.
Ja und dann geht diese ganze klimper wieder los und so oder so sieht es derzeit danach aus dass.
Es ein ende des monats ein anderen premierminister gibt als die wir jetzt haben als richtig vorzustellen wie johnson.
Und die wahrscheinlichkeiten zeigen eigentlich dahin dass wir halt entweder in diesem jahr oder im nächsten jahr generell election haben.
Aber nur die wird nicht stattfinden so und dann wird es neuwahlen geben und diese neuwahlen werden halt genauso wie die nächsten wahlen in den usa ein blutiger kampf werden,
insbesondere,
durch das wahlsystem was in großbritannien vorherrscht dass first post also es mehrheits wahlrecht indem du quasi nur abgeordnete aus.
Aus den einzelnen wahlkreisen im parlament hast die den gewonnen haben also die dort am meisten stimmen bekommen haben.
Da gibt's halt auch keine stichwahl oder so dass ihr wirklich richtige mehrheit haben müssen sondern es reicht halt wenn du einundzwanzig prozent hast und die anderen haben alle nur zwanzig.
Und dadurch dass du so ein feld hast von parteien laber,
dem stories und brexit partei die alle so potenziell irgendwo so zwischen fünfzehn und fünfundzwanzig dreißig prozent rumgeistern je nachdem von was für den wahlkreis du jetzt gerade sprichst lässt sich das überhaupt nicht einschätzen,
ob man da durch zufall ein linksruck oder durch zufall einen totalen rechtsruck oder irgendwas dazwischen bekommt,
das ist vollkommen unvorhersehbare seh bar hängt auch sehr davon ab wie sehr sich lieber noch weiter blamieren wird.
Würde hoffen.
Dass dass es ein überraschungsei sie gibt der liberale demokraten und dass es am ende irgendwie reicht eine koalitions regierung zu vom.
Die dieses spektrum aufnimmt also wo die liberale demokraten mit den laber und vielleicht mit der fdp zusammen es schaffen irgendwie eine regierung zu formen.
Das wäre die rettung aber das lässt sich derzeit überhaupt noch nicht vorhersagen.
Also so so sieht's aus ich denke wir werden uns auch noch im nächsten jahr mit dem brexit thema rumschlagen,
die probieren alles aber es wird auch genauso alles probiert das zu verhindern und die das parlament hat alle alle mittel also es,
sie haben es selber noch in der hand ja es wird damit dort die tricks gespielt und ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen was da noch,
das kann ich euch jetzt noch mal irgend so ein so ein so ein drachen aus irgendeinem irgend 'ner kiste entlassen werden und dann haben sie wieder irgendein gesetz von dreizehnhundert zweiundsiebzig gefunden wo ja dass das so und so war ja
dass es nicht komplett auszuschließen in diesem land wo alles immer auf irgendwelchen historischen,
geschehnissen basiert und keine geschriebene verfassung gibt aber,
na ja zumindest nicht das was so die beobachter derzeit.
Jetzt haste der koran gefällt dir auch nicht gibt's denn sonst irgendwo in der nähe noch ein ähnlich großen idioten wie den john.
Dann gibt es natürlich auch noch ne wenn ihr von was.
Okay aber das ist in der nähe in der nähe von irgendwie regierungs möglichkeit in großbritannien.
Regierung nicht nee also das äh,
durch das mehrheits wahlrecht ist das halt relativ unwahrscheinlich also derzeit wird es eigentlich immer noch nur leber oder den tores zugetraut letzten endes wirklich eine mehr zu bekommen was allerdings sehr viel wahrscheinlicher ist ist,
dass es weiterhin ein hang parlament gibt also dass das sozusagen auch nach dieser wahl im prinzip sich nicht nennenswert was verändert hat bei den touris wird's halt so sein sie werden halt
alle klugen leute rausgeschmissen haben also haben sie ja teilweise jetzt schon so also der
nachfahren von winston churchill und so weiter den hat schon irgendwie aus der partei geworfen weil er halt es gewagt hat gegen seinen dumm kurs zu stimmen.
Das hätte churchill aber auch gemacht insofern.
Kommt ja immer davon der neue deutsche zu sein aber er konnte kaum weiter davon entfernt sein.
Das was wirklich also ich mein.
So die die fehlende auch nur entferntesten selbst erkenntnis von idioten ne die hat dieser welt wirklich eine ganze menge zusätzlicher idiot y eingebracht scheint mir meine.
Dass sie sich selber immer für total genial halten.
Stabile genieß sind das ja alle sind alles stabile genieß die einzelnen der nicht merken sind alle anderen.
Usa also ich schau mir dass du doch irgendwie gerade tatsächlich relativ amüsiert an.
Ich glaube ein erfolgreiches trump impeachment ist genauso wahrscheinlich wie ein nordirak brexit gerade aber.
Hey je ist das peinlich das ist so fein.
Auf jeden fall wenn sich beide länder jockey genauso wie usa von der scheiße halt nicht so schnell erholen also das das wird,
zehn jahre dauern bis bis bis sie ihr halbwegs wieder glaubwürdigkeit zurück erlangt haben und mal gucken wie lange es noch dauert bis diese zehnjahresfrist überhaupt beginnen darf.
So kommen wir zu zurück nach europa zurück in die netz politik.
Da ist er.
Das ist auch schön wir haben zwei eugh entscheidungen heute zu behandeln beide etwas,
ich würde sagen nennt man sowas,
der nährend so also,
so ein bisschen so okay machen wir denn jetzt damit die erste betrifft die cookie penner,
und bei dieser entscheidung geht es um artikel fünf absatz drei der private richtlinie,
der ist in deutschland kaum bekannt ist auch sehr schön dass ich meine zeit 'ne richtige sollte halt bekannt sein aber.
In deutsch auf deutschen,
webseiten sind daher so cookie banner deutlich subtile als bei internationalen betreibern was sind cookie banner cookie banner sind eine der eine der vielen
hindernisse die einem in den weg gelegt werden beim versuch eine webseite zu besuchen
ja wenn du jetzt irgendwie also erstmal kommt ja ein opfer lay an werbung dann cookie banner und dann kommt was weiß ich blocker blocker und was nicht alles mit den weg geworfen wird.
Aber die cookie banner sind ja quasi die zustimmung dass du bei besuch der seite cookies bekommen.
Wirst und die unterliegen also dem artikel fünf dem der richtige der regelt vertraulichkeit der kommunikation artikel.
Fünf absatz eins untersagt mithören abhören und speichern.
So wenn nicht notwendig ist da kommt nicht in der artikel zwei das rechtlich zulässige aufzeichnen von nachrichten und der damit verbundenen verkehrs
daten wenn das im rahmen einer rechtmäßigen geschäftspraktiken bis,
zum nachweis einer kommerziellen transaktion geschieht also
ne eins sagt erstmal du darfst nichts mithören zwei sagt naja wenn das irgendwie deine funktion ist dann darfst du natürlich irgendwie die nachrichten speichern.
Okay und jetzt kommt der artikel fünf absatz drei der lautet die mitgliedstaaten stellen sicher dass die benutzung elektronischer kommunikations netze,
für die speicherung von informationen oder den zugriff auf informationen die im endgerät des teilnehmers oder nutzers gespeichert sind.
Also du speichert etwas auf den seite des nutzers nur unter der bedingungen gestattet ist,
dass der betreffende teilnehmer oder nutzer gemäß der richtlinien fünfundneunzig vierundsechzig klare und umfassende informationen insbesondere über die zwecke der verarbeitung erhält.
Und durch den für diese verarbeitung verantwortlichen auf das recht hingewiesen wird diese verarbeitung zu verweigern.
Das betrifft eben ja also mit anderen worten es wird ja auf deinem gerät etwas gespeichert nämlich,
wenige kilo bald daten.
Form eines cookies ja unter der bedingung,
du über die zwecke aufgeklärt wurdest,
und dir das recht auf das recht hingewiesen wirst diese verarbeitung zu verweigern das passiert ja im weitesten sinne auch bei diesem cookie bananen,
hallo wir benutzen cookies sag mal ja oder nein und,
eben auch bei internationalen seiten durchaus detaillierter wurde nämlich gesagt wird okay so und so
sieht das aus jetzt geht der artikel aber der absatz aber noch weiter dies steht eine technischen speicherung oder dem zugang nicht entgegen wenn der alleinige zweck die durchführung oder erleichterung der übertragung eine nachricht
über ein elektronisches kommunikations nett ist oder soweit dies unbedingt erforderlich ist
um einen vom teilnehmer oder nutzer ausdrücklich gewünschten dienst der informationsgespräch schaft zur verfügung zu stellen das heißt wenn,
diese website jetzt oder dieser dienst etwas auf deiner seite speichert was eindeutig im zusammenhang mit deinen wünschen steht.
Zum beispiel dein browser cash die inhalte und jetzt irgendwie ein einfaches beispiel zu nehmen ne du willst ja ganz offensichtlich diese seite sehen die seite wird ja auch gespeichert auf,
deinem rechner,
auf deinem informationsveranstaltungen system da musst du jetzt nicht vorher nochmal zustimmen es eindeutig gewünscht aber dass du jetzt zum beispiel irgendwie noch ein tracking cookie von facebook dazu kriegst eben nicht.
Also es geht hier um die grundsatzfrage dass überhaupt information auf deinem,
endgerät gespeichert werden und das.
Nicht unbedingt erforderlich ist so und interessanterweise werden hier erst anbieter und dritt anbieter cookies überhaupt nicht unterschieden.
In diesem satz und,
wohl aber geht es um die erforderliche zeit weil wenn das nicht erforderlich ist dann musst du einwilligen also anderes beispiel wäre für absolut erforderliche cookie ist du legst dich irgendwo ein ne dann setzt über willst du ihn wieder benutzername passwort,
und dann bekommst du ein cookie der sagt du bist übrigens eingeloggt in dieser session,
mit den cookie sendet um noch ganz kurz erklären wie cookies gehen diese information die du als cookie bekommst sendet dein browser dann beim besuch diese,
für die der cookie gültig ist als harter typ peter mit das heißt bei jedem richtfest den du sendet den browser dann sendet an die domain die den cookie ausgeteilt hat oder für die der cookie gültig ist.
Wird diese information dann im herbst wieder mit gesendet also quasi,
übrigens hier ist das ist mein cookie inhalt für dich
und gib mal die seite was weiß ich facebook dot com slash und dann kriegt jetzt jeder jeder klein da eine andere eine andere facebookseite zurück und diese unterscheidung wird getroffen anhand,
des cookies denn die person nämlich haben indem beispielsweise der lockeren gespeichert ist und das wäre ok.
Ich wollte kurz vielleicht ein bisschen allgemeiner nochmal sagen dass.
Man hat immer so diesen eindruck in der ganzen debatte so cookies oh gott das das sind so diese privatsphäre gefährden dinge ja die wollen uns,
kekse füttern und uns irgendwie in die hölle lotsen und so
ich muss sagen so als als schulträger teilnehmer dieses internets ja und als mit dem web losgehen so die allerersten webseiten das waren so,
statischen webseiten man klickt von halb berlin zur halbzeit das war so die ursprüngliche idee und dann also egal ist ja ganz praktisch,
und dann fängt man an so okay okay dann dann dann ist das super dann.
Dann benutzen wir das sommer für noch weitere sachen und irgendwann kam dann eben genau das was du grade erwähnt hast du also lock in,
heiß ah das heißt zwischen dem einen klick und den nächsten klick muss irgendwie einen kontext bestehen,
weil er an die andere seite weiß ja nicht dass der zweite klick zum ersten gehört.
Und da sind dann halt cookies geboren worden das ist einfach eine reine technische geschichte um genau so was überhaupt erstmal,
sinnvoll zu machen und als dann irgendwann losging mit diesem,
oh cookies die große gefahr und das musst du alles mögliche bestätigen das ist man dann so als als als als historisch geprägter mensch davor denkt sich so so,
habt ihr noch alle irgendwie das ist teil des konzepts sowieso das das ist dazu natürlich ist dann eben diese bedrohung durch diese wir benutzen das jetzt,
um andere dinge als den eigentlichen zweck zu erfüllen und das dann halt meistens eben informationen für dritte dadurch kriegt ihr das dann eben
diese dynamik diese diese ganzen regulierung und letzten endes auch diese ganzen warnung,
nach sich gezogen hat und jetzt haben wir den salat.
Also 'ne andere glaube ich früh web zeitliche anwendungen für cookies sollen so warenkorb warenkorb
bevor du dich jetzt bevor du den account hast ja du musst ja du bist auf dem onlineshop
du entscheidest dich für vier bis acht paar schuhe ne und jetzt muss ja irgendwo gespeichert sein dass du dich gerade dafür interessierst in der regel dann eben auch weil du ein cookie hast weiß die webseite in ihrem ende aha ich habe hier in meiner tabelle in eintrag
das ist der nutzer x y drei vier sechs der spontan hier vorbeigekommen ist und sich bisher folgende acht paar schuhe in seinen,
warenkorb gesetzt hat ne dass das die website dich wiedererkennen kann und deinen context.
Ihrerseits irgendwie speichern und verändern kann das hat aber den unschönen effekt eben oder die unschöne eigenart wenn,
wenn eine website kann ja cookies geben aus welchem grund auch immer sie möchte.
Dass sie dich eben wieder erkennt und natürlich haben cookies auf der anderen seite beispielsweise diese facebook like buttons,
die ich weiß es gibt sie noch aber die gab 's auf jeden fall eine zeit lang als das internet sich noch da draußen abspielt und nicht auf facebook selber das war ja genau die idee dass facebook sich gesagt pass mal auf in jede website bauen wir so ein kleines bisschen ein,
was oder wir motivieren website ein klein bisschen kontext zu uns herzustellen und das kommt dann von facebook dot com,
und da haben wir haben wir den leuten in cookie gegeben,
mit anderen worten wir können die dann über den rest des internets irgendwie tracken oder,
werbe netzwerke die sagten pass mal auf in jede website wird in kleinen müssen ein bisschen von unseren doppelklick oder hast du nicht gesehen netzwerk ein und da verteilen wir ordentlich cookies und dann können wir die leute über ihren web besuch,
bewegen sodass ich ohne irgendwelche empirische daten zu haben sagen würde das tatsächlich die realität inzwischen ist,
dass der größere teil der cookies die wir so auf unseren endgeräten haben nicht unbedingt für uns in,
also nicht unbedingt in notwendig ist für das was wir tun uns auch nicht bekannt ist und im zweifelsfall eher tracking aufgaben dient so,
wäre jetzt so meine vorsichtige schätzung es gab.
Es gibt aber auch schon sehr lange natürlich diese versuche,
die gute cookie von dem schlechten cookie zu unterscheiden geht natürlich nicht so wirklich also die meisten browser versuchen.
Also du sagst im prinzip den browser pass auf du gehst auf eine seite dann kannst du gerne von der seite,
cookies akzeptieren die oben in der adresse zeile steht wenn da aber andere sachen eingebunden sind dann will ich von denen bitte keine cookies haben nur dass das tun viele browser inzwischen.
Dann gibt es ja irgendwie google analytics setzt ihr den cookie und so also die technologie ist erstmal neutral ein größerer teil,
aber sie wird natürlich genutzt für allerlei luca und die idee war eben diese,
private richtlinie war das dem da irgendwie diesen wild wuchs ein bisschen entgegen zu wirken.
So jetzt ist also der streit fall hier im gewinnspiel anbieter der
einwilligung zu werbung haben will in denen auch cookies zugelassen werden und aus irgendwelchen gründen wird dieser fall verhandelt und landet dann eben beim eugh und der eugh sollte drei fragen beantworten,
erstens reicht für eine cookie einwilligung ein voraus gewähltes kästchen aus mit anderen worten die wurden wird schon mal angeboten,
welche einwilligung du geben kannst muss nur noch ok.
Zweitens spielt es eine rolle ob cookies personenbezogene daten in teil.
Das ist auch ich meine die frage ist falsch weil also ich meine das cookie,
beinhaltet im zweifelsfall keine personenbezogene daten cookies werden selten,
benutzt um wirklich größere mengen daten oder kontexte auf nutzerinnen seite zu speichern sondern die entsprechend letztendlich einfach einem,
das ist eigentlich nur ein younique identifiziere damit die webseite weiß ach du bist diese session und für die session hab ich in meinem speicher format bei mir in meiner schönen datenbank folgende sachen gespeichert aber,
natürlich stellte sich die frage weil es ja.
Weil sie da ein privates einen datenschutz aspekt vermuten und jetzt gibt es aber diese,
datenschutzgrundverordnung und e-privacy richtlinie deswegen personenbezogene daten haben sie da gefragt und dann noch die dritten.
Die dritte frage welche mindestanforderungen gehören denn in so einen cookie-hinweis,
das wir benutzen cookies sage ja,
oder musst du mehr da reinschreiben jetzt entscheidet der eugh ja also so ein vorausgewählt des kästchen reicht nicht für die,
informierte einwilligung und aufklärung gemäß e-privacy richtige ob diese cookies personenbezogenen sind ist,
nach e-privacy richtlinie aber irrelevant weil die richtige ja nur regelt dass du das hier überhaupt etwas auf dem computer gespeichert.
Und drittens sagen sie dann naja die mindestanforderungen für so eine,
guck die zustimmung sind erstens die allgemeine datenschutzerklärung wie der andere punkt die funktions dauer des cookies also cookies haben nämlich eine,
eine speicher dauer nach der browser sie einfach wegwerfen wird.
Und wer darauf zugriff hat,
wo man auch sagen also auf 'n cookie zugriff die domain für dies gültig ist so,
schwierig ne das heißt zum beispiel du kannst wenn du facebook dot com bist kannst du cookies vergeben für facebook.
Wenn du bist kannst du aber nur für sub domains hinter dir cookies vergeben ganz nicht für höhere,
ebenen cookies vergeben wenn ich das richtig erinnere also wer darauf zugefahren stellt natürlich dann auch wieder die frage cookie selber ist nicht das thema naja,
interessant finde ich personenbezogenen heit spielt keine rolle dass wir die entscheidung zwei.
Hätte nach dsgvo eine rolle gespielt hier sind wir aber in der richtlinie und die regelt eben den schutz,
von informationen auf dem endgerät und weil der cookie auf dem endgerät ist hier die personenbezogenen,
irrelevant also das richtige lehnt sich ja eigentlich an dem grundrecht auf gewährleistung der vertraulichkeit und integrität informationstechnik systeme,
an ja also mit anderen worten kannst du deinem eigenen gerät vertrauen wenn andere da auf einmal was draus speichern dürfen so wird halt über cookies diskutiert.
Na ja und,
heißt es also dieser richtlinie entsprechend sind eigentlich die deutschen gesetze nicht die das telemedizin gesetzt was also diese cookies sachen regelt deswegen,
wird jetzt das bundeswirtschaftsministerium einen neuen gesetzentwurf vorliegen der im telemedizin gesetz
die vorgaben regelt die sich dann eben an das eu-recht an.
Ja ende vom lied ist es ist relativ unklar was jetzt die auswirkungen sind,
dieses urteils sowohl auf eu-ebene als auch auf deutscher ebene.
Und ich finde ja schon also diese ganze also cookies werden zum tracking benutzt das ist richtig wenn du den die,
cookies nimmst ja wenn du deinen browser konfiguriert dass er die cookies von bestimmten domains nicht akzeptiert oder,
dass er eben nur von der domäne du initial primär besuchst gerade die cookies akzeptiert und nicht von dem eingebunden
google tracker ja dann.
Werden kommen javascript zum einsatz die versuchen deinen browser zu fingerprint die also sagen okay welche schriften sind hier installiert wie groß ist das,
was haben wir hier für eine pm interesse welches land und so weiter und so versuchen ob quasi diesen unique,
cookie den sie dir jetzt nicht mehr selber geben können irgendwie anders zu rechnen über individuelle konfiguration deines gerätes.
Was ihnen auch gelingt ja die ergebnisse da sind sehr fürchterlich das heißt irgendwie geht das jetzt so ein bisschen.
An dem eigentlichen problem vorbei und ja jetzt weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht ich meine,
es ist vollkommen klar diese ganze cookie abfrage reis total nervig und weitgehend auch sinnlos die leute sind einfach so dermaßen darauf konditioniert solange irgendwie auf exakt und okay zu klicken
bis sie endlich irgendwie mal das
bekommen was sie eigentlich haben wollten und von daher kannst du da tausend regulierung machen was da noch alles reingeschrieben werden muss und lesen sie sich noch dieses fünf seitige dokument durch und
bestätigen sie dass es jetzt in jeder ihrer denkbaren lebenssituation die richtige entscheidung ist für die nächsten drei jahre,
das macht einfach keiner und deswegen denke ich mal muss man sich hier sehr viel mehr automatisiert bare technische lösung gedanken machen,
wo halt einfach klar ist dass bestimmte dinge einfach so nicht gespeichert werden können und,
ich hab da jetzt auch keine keine liste und hat sicherlich auch seine technischen grenzen aber da müssen wir irgendwie hinkommen weil es,
aber nicht sein dass dass man sich da die ganze zeit durch so ein,
wahnsinn durchhangeln muss der am ende einfach nichts bringt weil du überhaupt nicht einschätzen kannst
worauf hat das jetzt ein bezug hier sind sicherlich auch die browser hersteller gefragt die an der stelle einfach dieses ganze die ganze da erreichung die ganze darstellung von
wo steht denn jetzt was über mich auch einfacher gestalten müssen und hier ist auch noch die standardisierten.
Die web standardisierte institute gefragt hier einfach mal das alles soweit zu absolvieren dass man das eben auch einfacher einstellen kann.
Wenn man einfach sagt so ja das und das will ich einfach nicht und dann hab ich auf eine seite und dann ist das halt auch nicht und.
Dann ist es erstmal so lange und dann sagt die website.
Jetzt kann ich aber nicht funktionieren bitte hier ausnahme,
das sehen wir natürlich auch immer aber über diese seite müsse müsste der druck gemacht werden ich sehe mich jetzt grad nicht in der lage ja wirklich eine qualifizierte technische forderung aufzustellen wie man es denn jetzt machen soll es auch alles nicht so einfach aber ich glaube,
irgendwie nicht dass wir über diese ganze regulatorischen ebene zu einer lösung kommt werden es erhöht natürlich den druck und von daher ist es vielleicht.
Ja demnächst aber eher alles in apps oder was haben wir als nächstes tim gucken browser wie lange noch wann kommt der browser fit.
Oder es kommt der browser zurück auf tot gesagt.
Ich glaube wir werden erstmal weiterhin mit dem,
das wetter seine vorteile hat seine nachteile apps an ihre vorteile um ihre nachteile so und.
Bald beides wird bleiben nichts wird das andere verdrängen sicherlich in bestimmten bereichen.
Aber die technologie ist einfach noch viel zu praktisch und sinnvoll als dass sie dass sie die irgendwie aussterben sehr.
Aber wenn halt so unternehmen wie google denn haupt und interesse halt werbung und trecking ist den,
meist genutzt browser dieser welt stellt dann ist das halt so mit den fortschritten in dem bereich so 'ne sache ja,
gibt es halt nicht so viele an an wenn er anbieter die die dieses seminar und diese technologische power haben von google,
das einzige einzige alternative an der stelle ist halt eigentlich apple die halt einfach anderes business modell fahren was nicht auf werbung basiert und dem,
auch ein anderes interesse haben dir solche preis die einstellung zu ermöglichen,
aber seit auch nicht plattform übergreifend auf windows gibt es in dem sinne gar keine,
option eine andere als als cro mittlerweile jetzt wo sogar microsoft auf derselben technologische basis.
Also mein vorschlag wär auf jeden fall dass die nächste regulierung sollte auf jeden fall sagen.
Ein adblocker blocker das nur nach meiner erklärten willkürlichen wesentlichen einverstanden.
Und die muss klein die muss das muss in einem hetzer in einem h d peter muss stehen ich möchte gerne ein adblocker blocker sehen ja den hat er muss ich bei der ford ist der offen nein,
und wenn ich den auf ja sätze dann das adblocker.
Adblocker blogger geben sonst nicht das das finde ich noch ganz gut.
Locker blocker geben ich meine.
Locker müssen weg weil das nervt das ist wirklich das nimmt den spaß weg.
Schlechte verlierer schlechte verlierer kommen mit adblocker bloggern und da da würde ich auch protokoll ebene und auf gesetzlicher ebene mit rap konische strafen sagen wenn ich ein adblocker blogger sehe den ich nicht spezifisch angefordert habe.
Dann sofort kartell.
Ja jetzt machen wir ein fass auf ne wenn ihr jetzt diese ganze wie finanzieren sich web angebote ne so das,
kann man kann man von irgendjemanden erwarten dienstleistung,
un finanzierbar nicht finanzierbar anzubieten die kann man nicht,
und so viel finanzierung optionen jenseits der werbung hat das netz halt noch nicht so geboren es gibt einzelne bereiche in denen abos und einfach klassische du gibst mir geld ich geb dir,
es gibt die dienstleistung wo das funktioniert aber es funktioniert eben für vieles vermutlich auch nicht.
Ich wollte damit nur zum ausdruck bringen dass es eine relativ abitur leere ausfall ist an dingen die im web nach meiner einverständnis passieren dürfen und nicht dieses e-privacy richtigen dinge damit den cookies kommt mir ein bisschen komisch.
Zweites eugh-urteil ist um einiges einfach und lässt uns ähnlich ratlos zurück dieser fall kommt vom obersten gerichtshof in österreich ja und,
da gab es beleidigende äußerungen gegen die frühere parteichefin der österreichischen grünen,
ähnlich wie was wir in der letzten folge behandelt haben ich glaube renate können das war sicherlich auch schon einmal parteichefin der grünen partei weiß ich aber nicht genau.
Ich glaube wir hatten das sogar auch behandelt nee bist du sicher.
Renate künast haben wir behandelt aber nicht den fall von eva.
Evan klar oh je das ist wirklich ein schwieriger name shinichi.
Ich glaube ich nicht.
Ps
Wo man das okay aber der ist wirklich schwierig tim klar wischen peace.
Ja das stimmt wahrscheinlich jetzt noch nicht mal eine grüne alt.
Unter den grünen da ist man ja gerne auch per du na die reden sich ja gerne mit vornamen an also eva eva hat,
wurde auf facebook unter anderem als korrupter trampeln und miese volksverräter bezeichnet,
so dann hat sie eine unterlassungserklärung fügung hinbekommen und wollte gerne dass auch eine löschung wort gleicher und sinn gleicher beleidigungen stattfindet bei facebook.
Und sie will also quasi das posting selber über das sie sich beklagt hat und sinngemäß ähnliche aber anders formulierte beleidigungen sollen ebenfalls von facebook verschwinden.
Und damit hat sie in den meist in den unteren instanzen in österreich recht bekommen und dann landet das eben am obersten gerichtshof,
von österreich und derzeit in dem eugh vorgelegt und der sollte jetzt also prüfen.
Ob diese dieser dieser wunsch von eva.
Dem der eu-richtlinie über den elektronischen geschäftsführer kehr entspreche dir diese die eu richtigen über den elektronischen geschäfts verkehr klärt dieses verhältnis,
dass eben ein,
nicht,
für die.
Also der horst provider ist jetzt quasi hier dieses online nicht für die von den nutzern veröffentlichen informationen verantwortlich ist dass das provider privileg,
bis sie auf die rechtsstaatlichkeit hingewiesen wurden,
ja wenn aber jetzt eben die eva klar sagt übrigens es ist rechtswidrig zu sagen ich bin ein,
eine miese volksverräter drin und ein korrupt sei eine misse volksverräter drin oder ein oder ein korrupter trampeln dann ab dem moment muss ist facebook eben,
angehalten das zu löschen und jetzt.
Gibts ja im urheberrecht durchaus den anspruch dass das auch in zukunft passiert da sind wir eben beim thema uploadfilter und das hat sie jetzt quasi gesagt okay,
sie möchte dass das für diese behauptung über sie auf facebook eben auch in zukunft gilt und automatisiert,
entfernt wird jetzt hat der eugh general anwalt der ja dann da regelmäßig vor trägt gesagt ja also er wird das so sehen dass facebook bei rechtsverstöße genauer prüfen und auch weltweit löschen muss.
Und das ergebnis dieses urteils ist facebook muss auch wort gleichen inhalt entfernt.
Oder den zugang dazu sperren unabhängig davon wer den auftrag für die speicherung gegeben hat das heißt facebook muss auch in zukunft die behauptung.
Eva klavier schnick sei ein korrupter trampeln oder diese volksverräter löschen.
Voraussetzung dafür ist aber dass die informationen zuvor für rechts wie dich erklärt wurden also nur wenn es ein urteil gibt dass diese äußerungen rechtswidrig ist dann muss facebook auch wort gleichen inhalt.
Entfernen oder den zugang dazu sperren aber es gibt quasi ein urteil vorbehalt.
Auch sinn gleiche beleidigungen muss facebook entfernen oder sperren.
Das aber nur wenn es automatisiert möglich ist.
Die zu löschen den sinn gleichen kommentare müssen,
in ihren einzelheiten genau beschrieben sein,
es muss dem anbieter möglich bleiben sie eine hand,
automatisierte techniken ausfindig zu machen.
Sagte ein sprecher des gerichts also die du musst quasi nach dem urteil sagen also hier volksverräter rin und,
sinngemäß ist die verschiedenen weisen auf die die verknüpften im internet volksverräter falsch schreiben.
Und andere sachen was weiß ich was was sie noch.
So was noch sinngemäß,
so und jetzt sagt facebook in einer stellungnahme dieses urteil wird kritische fragen zur meinungsfreiheit und zur rolle auf die internetunternehmer beim monitoring interpretieren und in fan von äußerungen die in einem einzelnen land illegal sein können spielen sollten.
Und da bin ich fast ein bisschen bei facebook also unabhängig davon dass.
Niemand sich irgendwie beschimpfen und herabwürdigend lassen muss.
Und es da diese gesetze gibt und die lösch ansprüche finde ich das schon,
irgendwie vorsichtig zu gehen mit vorsicht zu genießen das urteil dass man jetzt irgendwie sinn gleiche beleidigungen ebenfalls,
entfernen kann und dann klingt eigentlich auf anhieb,
es klingt das ja sinnvoll die voraussetzung zu haben dass die information zuvor für rechtswidrig erklärt.
Aber gleichzeitig also bedeutet das ja wenn ich mich nie dagegen wäre dann darf das weiter verbreitet werden.
Aber in dem moment wo ich mich erfolgreich richtig dagegen gewehrt habe schon,
das aber wiederum heißt dass ich eigentlich nur die leute ging sowas wehren können die den die stammen dazu haben und irgendwie auch die anwälte dafür ähnlich wie hast du hier ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr das besprochen haben ulf poschardt dieser,
wählt,
chefredakteur glaube ich der auf twitter behauptet hat,
herbert grönemeyer sei aus steuerlichen gründen nach london gezogen.
Was nicht stimmt weil herbert grönemeyer in deutschland seine steuern zahlt und einfach nur aus spaß in london wohnt weil ihm da besser gefällt so,
das hat irgendwie dieser ulf poschardt ist ja jetzt nicht der weißeste und hat dann irgendwie das getwittert.
Und hat sich sofort eine,
eine abmahnung mit unterlassen forderte mit aufforderung zur richtig stellung und unterlassungserklärung von ulf poschardt gefordert ulf poschardt hatte dann doch nicht einmal die größe die man ja von einem journalisten,
sowieso erwarten würde ja also von einem von irgendeinem spinner auf twitter,
würde man jetzt erwarten dass er damit und souverän umgeht,
von jemandem der journalist oder gar chefredakteur ist würde man natürlich erwarten hey,
das ist im interesse meiner eigenen ehre,
diese falsche behauptung sofort zu revidieren und selbstverständlich unterschreibe ich jede unterlassungserklärung die eindeutig falsche fakten betrifft die ich in die welt gesetzt hat ulf poschardt hingegen natürlich ein mensch,
ohne ehre ohne kultur ohne journalistischen anstand hat natürlich dann noch auf twitter irgendwie eine umfrage gestartet hui ui ich kriege mir wird hier mit einem anwalt gedroht was soll ich tun ja wie es halt die menschen,
bei bild verlag springer sowieso tun dir eben kein eher begriff haben sondern den erst in einer umfrage noch einmal für im einzel verklärt müssen die umfrage ging dann eben auch so dahin so alter.
Es gibt eine gegendarstellung ab so gibt 'ne richtig stellung ab du.
Bist du denn vereine so das war jetzt das was in seiner eigenen umfrage dann rauskam und jetzt kann natürlich der grönemeyer,
ich glaube ich bin hat er als nächstes dann noch abgemahnt irgend so ein afd spinner ich glaube den höcke,
der hat das nämlich auch behauptet der rück hat sich dann auch nochmal einen gefangen ja aber das heißt letztendlich dass nur jemand wie.
Und das interessante ist an dem ort in dem fall ist ja nie zum urteil gekommen,
na der grönemeyer hat einfach nur gesagt übrigens falsch du verlierst den du verlierst das ohnehin deswegen fordere ich dich jetzt zur abgabe einer unterlassungserklärung ab also weiß ich irgendwie nicht wie damit jetzt hier,
umzugehen ist ob jetzt ob wir wollen das jetzt nur bestimmte leute die anwälte und zeit haben sich vor,
gericht quasi zukünftige löschung von behauptungen er klagen können.
Also das kommt mir.
Vor allem würde das ja jetzt auch im umkehrschluss bedeuten wenn jetzt in ungarn.
Irgendeine aussage als rechtswidrig festgestellt wird oder in polen ja dass das dann weltweit gelöscht zu werden hat,
ich könnte mir doch bestimmte konstellationen vorstellen die eine sportliche auseinandersetzung nachsicht ziehen.
Also da bei aller ne das ist natürlich dessen unschönes thema beleidigungen im internet sind ein total geknackt das phänomen.
Und,
es gibt eben auch unterschiede jetzt ehrlich gesagt zwischen irgendwie,
den beleidigungen die jetzt hier eben einfach im beleidigungen bereich sind ne volksverräter drin oder,
oder drecks fotze was irgendwie über renate künast gesagt wurde das sind ja immer so es gibt eben beleidigungen die sagen mehr,
über die beleidigt über die person aus die versucht zu beleidigen als das ziel der beleidigung,
also es gibt beleidigung da gilt einfach der spaß es gibt einen der versucht zu beleidigen und an der sich beleidigen lässt,
also von bestimmten äußerungen lasse ich mich nicht beleidigen dann gibt's unwahrheit tatsachen behauptungen wie die die der chefredakteur der woche der tageszeitung die welt auf twitter in die in die welt gesetzt hat in die welt.
Ne da muss man sich natürlich irgendwie gegen wehren das sind eben eher verletzend de und tatsachen behauptungen aber jetzt irgendwie so beleidigung,
ich weiß ich finde es schwierig und man sieht ja genau das jetzt irgendwie offenbar nach heutigen stand könnte also die,
eva klar fischer,
sich dagegen zur wehr setzen als korrupter trampeln bezeichnet zu werden und zwar automatisiert in zukunft auf facebook hat den rechtsanspruch während renate künast nach aktuellem nach aktuelle rechtsprechung das nicht hat.
Weil da gibt 's jetzt gerade ein urteil wo drin steht renate künast als solches zu bezeichnen,
ist akzeptabel ist eine auseinandersetzung in der sache und spannenderweise,
also ich meine das urteil wird ja eh kassiert werden wenn wenn wir hier noch irgendwie ein hauch an,
rechtsstaat irgendwo haben aber das interessante ist dass diese diese sache bei renate künast sei es eine auseinandersetzung in der sache gewesen.
Die bezieht sich ja irgendwie auf den inhalt des artikel,
ja und das wiederum ist ja sehr interessant wenn das jetzt aus irgendwelchen gründen eine auseinandersetzung in der sache weil sie netto darfst du darfst sagen renate künast ist eine,
drecks fotze wenn das in dem und dem kontext steht ja wenn es gerade über sexuelle themen geht darfst du das aber in anderen kontext nicht wenn das jetzt aus irgendwelchen gründen.
Akzeptabel das urteil in deutschland wäre und ein rechtswidriges urteil dann wiederum wie soll dein facebook damit umgehen,
wenn du darfst das in einigen kontexten darfst du die behauptung aufstellen anderen nicht,
spätestens damit könnt ihr dann irgendwie facebook auch nicht mehr umgehen also mir kommt das irgendwie ich bin ungerne auf der seite von facebook aber irgendwie eine zukünftige automatisierte löschung von behauptungen zu,
zu verlangen erscheint mir ein bisschen wild.
Ja wieder so ein bereich wo es extrem schwierig ist richtigen umgang zu finden weil wie man es macht macht man's falsch so dass das ist halt das ding ne auf der.
Und wieder macht wie das machst jetzt ausgenutzt.
Genau also es wird nicht ohne lupus bleiben und dementsprechend bleibt schwierig hier was ist wenn sich das später vielleicht ist ja irgendwann mal ein coolen korrupter trampeln was dann ist er wieder rückgängig machen.
Müsste rechtlich müsst ihr dann erstmal gesetzlich verbrieft werden ja.
Festgestellt werden ja ich will jetzt ein korrupter trampeln sein.
Also beide urteile.
Ja
Entschuldigung beide urteile kommen ja wie herausforderungen vor.
Ab im bunker mit uns.
Weißt du was auch eine herausforderung ist das ding ist eine herausforderung und zwar.
So so.
Genau die haben also diese die jungs vom cyber bunker wird das glaube ich auf niederländisch ausgesprochen die haben ja,
die diese sache mit dem posting schon seit vielen jahren sehr,
sehr wörtlich genommen als sie neunzehnhundertsechsundneunzig schon in den niederlanden ein bunker kaufen und dort,
hosting anbot,
hosting im sinne ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau ich glaube sie haben ne das klassische hosting programm gemacht kriegst space mieten du kannst fast als ich,
du kannst 'n server oder vw server irgendwie dort mieten klassisches hosting angebot.
Und silber bunker war schon längere zeit bekannt also die haben
eine lange zeit auch pirat gehortet und ich erinnere mich dunkel an irgendwelche berichte wo dann auch hier im burger
das ist der das ist der bunker wo sicher gerostet wird als hätte jetzt irgendwie sag ich mal der bunker irgendwas damit zu tun
das ob da dein hosting sicher ist oder nicht ne also ok,
physische sicherheit ist hier gewährleistet ist in anderen koloss ähnlich aber die haben natürlich hier schon
ein mit dieser mit diesem standort bunker 'ne 'ne 'ne interessante werbung.
Getrieben.
Ist halt die frage was so sein dein bedrohung s modell ist ja also ich meine am ende müssen die die tür auch aufmachen wenn die polizei kommt es ist ja nicht so dass sie sich dann in ihrem booker ein bunkern,
also vielleicht keine ahnung also vielleicht macht ihr das ja auch aber ich denke mal zu seiner normalen
server tür wie man sieht so 'n datenschutz verarbeiten im betrieb vorfindet dürfte der unterschied ist nicht so groß sein ja vielleicht eine dickere tür aber die muss halt unter den selben bedingungen geöffnet werden,
es sei denn steht halt wirklich das militär davor ne und am ende ist auch ein bisschen schorle leute finden einfach geiler.
Also dieser dieser cyber bunker hat ja tatsächlich der deutsche jetzt dass der war gar nicht so,
so schlecht also der war.
Der war noch nicht so lange außer betrieb der war gebaut achtzig tage lang also als als die bundeswehr die noch betrieben hat konntest du den achtzig tage lang im kriegsfall autark betreiben.
Und äh dreihundertfünfzig soldaten darin am leben halten und der konnte auch irgendwie weiß ich nicht der war gebaut um irgendwie eine nukleare ein schlag irgendwie aus nicht allzu großer entfernung.
Auszuhalten also je nachdem wo dann der.
Wo die atombombe einschlägt hättest du älteste sicher sein können dass du zwar relativ bald,
vielleicht das zeigt dass das zeitliche segnen ist aber der punkt deine server in dem bunker hätten eben längere zeit noch überlebt als du ja was jetzt nicht bei jeder,
bei jedem bunker der fall ist ok kommen wir zurück zum thema die haben da also
erstmal in den niederlanden so ein so ein server raum betrieben in einem bunker haben damit die marke cyber bunker aufgebaut
zwei hat's in ihrem niederländischen bunker
beim löschen und den danach verdauern folgenden untersuchungen hat die polizei dann ein drogen labor in dem bunker gefunden es war also schon damals irgendwie klar dass die vielleicht,
nicht ganz so dass ihr 'ne ganz gute idee von ihrem bunker haben was sie da machen wollen zweitausendelf haben sie den bunker den sie da in holland hatten verkauft und zwanzig dreizehn den neuen gekauft in wie heißt diese stadt ähnlich kompliziert
sie die grüne.
Traben tragen.
Trab trab wach ja,
da gab's ein bunker der wurde zwanzig dreizehn verkauft an die sie waren die einzigen bieter und handeln für dreihundertfünfzig,
tausend euro also bunker gekriegt.
Auf dem mond royal.
Siehst du den bunker da auf dem auf dem.
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so ganz so sicher aber es,
es gibt auf jeden fall eine landebahn da oben auf dem berg das ist ja so ein plateau berg da schönes gewerbegebiet da gibt's eine,
real ob das irgendwas mit diesem bunker zu tun hat kann ich nicht sicher sagen.
Aber da kann man auch schön wohnen irgendwie also da kann man schön wohnen ist auf jeden fall was zu holen wo der bunker jetzt genaues weiß.
Hätte hätte der bunker fenster hätten die auch vielleicht einen schönen ausblick haben können von ihrem und royal da oben.
Ja also ich vermute.
Ist das nicht da komm mal her also wir gucken gerade auf google ja so kleine ja müssen mal gucken.
Also zwanzig dreizehn haben die sich in den bunker gekauft ungefähr zu der zeit sind die mir auch nochmal aufgefallen weil die halten sich.
Angelegt mit spam house,
house ist eine ein betreiber von einer block liste auf der irgendwie,
ip-adresse beziehungsweise domains und m x domains von,
des versand verdächtigen,
servern gesammelt werden regelmäßig sehr ärgerlich auf der liste zu landen man landet dort aus unterschiedlichsten teilweise,
sehr absurden gründen und die haben auch regelmäßig fehlentscheidungen also es hat nicht den besten ruf,
hat aber dann irgendwie zwanzig dreizehn rum mal,
dies passau war die im silber bunker standen auf ihre black liste genommen
das hat dann die cyber bunker leute wohl verärgert woraufhin die dann einen auf service angriff auf spam haus gemacht haben.
Und der ging dann in die geschichte ein als der stärkste service angriff bis dahin.
Ja
in dem zusammenhang wurde einer der betreiber dann zwanzig dreizehn auch in spanien verhaftet und in spanien erklärt er habe also diplomatischen status und er sei nicht der telekommunikation minister und außenminister,
der cyber bunker republik,
und der spanien der spanische polizist sagt dazu erschienen das wohl auch nicht für ein scherz zu halten,
also wie gesagt dieses cyber booker leute sind ein bisschen komisch das hat dann irgendwie zwanzig fünfzehn zu offiziellen ermittlungen geführt weil die eben immer mehr misse taten.
Festgestellt haben und jetzt gab es eine verhaftung.
Vielleicht war das ja boris becker.
Ist er auch in reis bäcker jetzt inzwischen.
Ja bei der löffel behauptet der diplomatischen status und könnte wenig an irgendwelchen obs korn.
Der unterschied ist dass boris becker den im zweifelsfall hat hatte er nicht kann er sich.
Hatte er nicht nee ist alles aberkannt worden hat er sich alles nur gekauft.
Ja eben hat er sich gekauft.
Wurde nicht anerkannt.
Okay komisch.
Gelaufen.
Ähm ja jetzt zwanzig fünfzehn und in deutschland ermittelt und sind jetzt.
Wir haben jetzt die cyber bunker betreiber beschuldigt dass sie diesen ort.
Geschaffen haben absichtlich um dort,
quasi hosting für illegale inhalte zu bieten also,
services schwarz märkte im internet,
unter umständen auch hacking angriffe die von diesen servern ausgehen und sich eben gezielt als pulled poster beworben zu haben mit dem ziel für illegale
machenschaften im internet dort hosting anzubieten und,
das betrifft jetzt in deutschland ein bereich der provider haftung wieder ja wo nämlich der,
betreiber verantwortlich ist der horst da aber nicht also wenn ich morgen mich entscheiden würde eine illegale webseite zu errichten und das was ich auf,
bei einem doll einen provider meiner wahl zu tun dann wäre dieser provider eben wiederum nur dafür verantwortlich sofern er davon kenntnis erlangt.
So sollte ich also mich morgen entscheiden einen drogenmarkt platz auf einem hin service zu betreiben und diesen server was weiß ich in hier in berlin weil irgendein hostel bei irgendeinem provider ins regal zu schieben.
Dann wäre das wäre dieser hostel dafür nicht verantwortlich.
Als betreiber dieses services wäre das sehr wohl,
und das ist jetzt auch das interessante in diesem fall banker bunker.
Weil die jetzt quasi sagen die general,
anwartschaft koblenz war das glaube ich die da einmarschiert sind die sagen es kann nicht sein dass die nicht wussten was für geschäfte über ihre server die da stehen
abgewickelt wurden
wir gehen davon aus dass die beschuldigten ein auf längere dauer angelegten organisierten zusammenschluss bilden der dem gemeinsamen interesse diente finanzielle gewinne zu erwirtschaften mit illegaler tätigkeit und deswegen hat er die jetzt geschnappt,
oder werfen sie in nur vor bildung einer kriminellen vereinigung.
Ich habe in der gruppe eine klare hierarchie und arbeitsteilung geherrscht einige hätten leitung und management aufgabe übernommen und es geht eben darum dass sie ziel hatten diese illegalen,
tätigkeiten dort zu ermöglichen ein bisschen auf dünn mais wenn du mich fragst.
Also ich sehe auch schon wieso die,
kurz vorm einschlafen waren jetzt richtig schlagartig wach geworden sind weil die meist oft
keine ahnung haben was auf ihren eigenen zaubern eigentlich tatsächlich abgeht aber jetzt als roster auch noch darüber kenntnis zu haben was irgendwelche server die man da drin stehen hat die irgendwie voll verschlüsselte kommunikation
betreiben was die da tun wie denn,
ich meine wie soll man denn davon also ich kann nicht ausschließen dass es so war.
Aber man kann halt auch nicht nachweisen dass es so,
war oder war vermutlich kann man also vielleicht kann man das auch nachweisen aber ich würde nicht sagen dass es jetzt generell eine aussage korrekt ist die da sagt,
kann ja nicht sein dass ihr das nicht gemerkt.
Natürlich kann das sein dass man das nicht gemerkt hat weil wenn es halt gut versteckt ist ja und man auch generell eigentlich als hostel jetzt nicht unbedingt in dem business der überwachung der eigenen user beschäftigt sein sollte,
meine was soll das denn kriegst du 'ne mail von ja wir haben da irgendwie so ein,
dummes tool aufgesetzt das hat sich pakete angeschaut und die haben bei unserer meinung nach die falsche checks und wir haben es mal abgeschaltet.
Du wirst du als haushalt nicht gerade besonders erfolgreich werden,
das ist ja auch unangemessen also willst du dich das dir dein hose irgendwie die quere kommen irgendwelche annahmen darüber macht was was was du jetzt tust und wie soll man soweit ansehen ob es jetzt kriminelle energie transportiert oder nicht.
Es ist tatsächlich sehr also.
Haben wir nur so eine meldung heute wo man irgendwie am ende nicht weiß was.
Wenn du wenn du dir wenn du dir wenn du dir die website von den anschaust jetzt offline aber in der way back maschine findest du die noch ne da ja.
Du meinst die hätten nicht so besonderen und so weiter da stehen sollen oder ich sag mal.
Also im im dorf wird berichtet die hätten halt um den bunker heraus ganz viele aggressive runde runde auch noch rumrennen gehabt,
und so alt.
Hier guck mal da ist auch eine luft aufnahme aber das das betrifft glaube ich dass es jetzt die alte webseite die betrifft noch die niederländischen nähe vor die ist aus dem.
Siebenundzwanzigster august zwanzig neunzehn da geben sie dann auch noch mit den spax von dem bunker an.
Wir haben dann auch irgendwie noch ein auto davor stehen mit einem foto von kennzeichen also.
So ist das ding in holland.
Irgendwie schon ne aber der aber irgendwie,
webseite war trotzdem noch das ist die version der website von vom april zwanzig neunzehn.
Also das ist irgendwie komisch jedenfalls ist das.
Tja man die die scheinen ja hier offenbar viele jahre hinter diesen leuten hinterher entwickelt in der herr ermittelt zu haben und sind sich offenbar ja relativ im klaren darüber dass du diese.
Dass du den über das hosting selber nicht so ohne weiteres ja habhaft wirst.
Also es wird auf jeden fall ein spannendes verfahren mit viel potenzial für und,
dadurch dass die den ja das ganze daten setter beschlagnahmt haben haben die jetzt auch unmengen an eben potenziell,
oder wie sie sagen illegalen webseiten also eine ganze reihe hinten services ist runter gegangen ich glaube wallstreet market ist einer,
der der hitze ist jetzt nicht mehr erreichbar sind der war relativ erfolgreich,
im handel mit legalisieren substanzen.
Und da gibt's natürlich jetzt auch nochmal 'ne ganze reihe anderer leute die ihren shit eben im bunker halten und dachten,
der stellt sich raus ist er gar nicht hat 'ne tür kann man reingehen und,
ich meine das war jetzt irgendwie eine größere operation g neun und wer da alles dran beteiligt war viele leute die da jetzt irgendwie von den betreibern verhaftet wurden das ist schon alles irgendwie.
Tja also ich meine die werden wahrscheinlich nicht über so viele jahre mit ihren ermittlungen weitergekommen und hätten am ende die leute mit der g neun gefangen wenn da nicht irgendwie auch.
Anhaltspunkte wären.
Nein es ist ja schon mal ein guter anhaltspunkt wenn dein alter bunker brennt und du hast ein drogen labor drin ne das passiert ja normal nicht wenn ein bunker hast weißt du.
Passiert die halt nicht.
Aber der da haben sie gesagt haben sie vermietet haben so untermieter gehabt klar wenn du bock hast hast du viel platz kannst du auch unter familien steht ja erstmal jetzt bleibt ihr ungelogen wie du mit deinem mit deinem immobilien eigentum umgeht.
Die lassen echt schon ganz schön dicken raushängen ja.
Das interessante an diesem bunker ist halt so also der hat halt der,
der stadt als er den burger gekauft hat halt erzählt so ja seine kunden sind unternehmen die.
In der ihre daten vor zerstörung durch atombomben schützen wollen oder so ne und da ist natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt,
der diese webseite ist jetzt immer für seriöse geschäftspartnerin nicht unbedingt ansprechend,
wenn du jetzt sagen würdest tag chef ich hab überlegt wir hosten hier im bunker guck mal,
da ist die website da würde jetzt das ist der alte cyber bunker,
den in holland der inder gebrannt hat da wird es jetzt auf anhieb nicht sagen.
Also würdest du schon fragen ob die in der lage sind eine mehrwertsteuer.
Ordentlich auf der rechnung auszuweisen und die würden im zweifelsfall sagen neben den bitcoin.
Also tja schwierige sache.
Zweihundertneunzig server wanda drin betrieben von vier niederländern neunundfünfzig neunundvierzig dreiunddreißig vierundzwanzig jahre alt eine zweiundfünfzigjährige alte deutsche und ein dreiundzwanzigjähriger deutscher wurden,
einhundertneununddreißig jahre ein dreiundzwanzigster deutscher und ein neununddreißigjährige bulgaren wundert 's alle verhaftet.
Sechs leute verdacht auf bildung einer kriminellen vereinigung tja und sie sagen es war der einzige zweck dieses rechenzentrum s die webseiten krimineller täter zu speichern und die sind ihre straftaten so erst zu ermöglichen.
Tja,
also das wird auf jeden fall ein ein interessantes verfahren weil das ja auch uns an das it-sicherheit gesetz zwei punkt null erinnert den referentenentwurf der da kursiert ist wo es eben auch so darum ging hier so etwas zu betreiben mit dem ziel.
Illegalen etwas zu ermöglichen wird ein ganz anderer straftatbestand.
Also ich bin auf jeden fall mal gespannt dass das werden wir auf jeden fall beobachten.
Wir haben heute nur so meldung wo irgendwas das.
Öl meldungen ne.
Ja wohl das gericht sowas beschlossen haben wir so.
Wie kann man sich das erklären ne aber das interessante an unserer heutigen sendung ist tim am ende kommt die auflösung warum.
Das alles so komisch ja und die auflösung kommt.
Wie so oft von michael kreis ja michael kreile hat nämlich festgestellt die social bots vor denen wir immer so viel angst haben.
Die sitzen schon in den parlamenten es gibt nämlich ein tool dass das von der indianer university blumigen vorgestellt wurde,
und das erkennt bots wir erinnern uns natürlich an.
Der bottom meter.
An michaels vortrag beim beim kongress wo eben diese ganzen automatisierten bot direktion,
mechanismen mal auseinander genommen hat und immer schöne beispiele gefunden hat für bots die dann doch recht lebt lebhaft,
erschienen glaube meinte auch irgendwie frank und ich sind auch bots zu so so viel prozent und also irgendein irgendeines dieser.
Dass du die nervt variante von von von denen es analyse man lässt sich sozusagen auf seinen,
testen.
Ja das geht genau.
Nicht nicht wie viele abstammung hast du irgendwie so aus dem ukrainischen raum sondern einfach wieso denn dann bot anteil.
Und das boot bottom meter kenne ich tatsächlich das war früher war das bot nord,
ja account in basel und liked account ist highscore amor.
So dann hat er michael krallt das ding benutzt ja der bottom meter und hat das mal die die parlamente,
der die landesparlamenten wenn ich das jetzt.
Also die abgeordneten der einzelnen parlamente quasi durch diesen durch diese analyse durch geschickt und mal geguckt so wie viel prozent die als bot klassifizieren werden.
Ja und im saarland sitzen im im saarländischen landtag sitzen vierzig prozent bots.
In bremen siebenunddreißig baden-württemberg dreiunddreißig komma neun schleswig-holstein dreiunddreißig komma neun brandenburg dreißig bayern dreißig niedersachsen vierundzwanzig einhalb ja also unglaublich was da in niedersachsen los ist ja bundestag
ah bundestag ist auch dabei neun komma zwei prozent der bundestagsabgeordneten sind bots.
Laut bottom meter ja also eine schöne schöne illustration der schwächen dieser ganzen automatisierten analyse methoden,
und viel mehr als die grafik die michael dazu zu tage gefördert hat braucht man glaub ich gar nicht mehr zu haben vorzuzeigen wenn irgendwelche,
gesetze oder parlamentarier wieder quasi.
Ich glaube wir haben auch wirklich andere sorgen als social bots.
Genau wir haben andere sorgen als social bots nämlich influencer.
Ja es sind vor allem nicht so soziale bots sondern sind einfach soziale menschen die das problem sind.
Dachte sich auch die cdu.
Wirklich.
Die haben sich überzeugt dass wieso wahrscheinlich lebt ja und,
also der generalsekretär der cdu paul ziemiak.
Hat sich jetzt langsam vom schock erholt ja und hat erkannt dass die cdu schwächen in der öffentlichkeitsarbeit hat,
und damit soll jetzt schluss sein er braucht eine baut nämlich jetzt auf eine schnelle eingreiftruppe,
eingreiftruppe mit geeigneten spinnen spinde toren für die sozialen medien also wir erinnern uns die csu ist ja mit,
also das war ja das war so peinlich dass es hier glaube ich kaum behandelt haben.
Und auch der angriff von am tor konnte irgendwie nicht ist nicht erfolgt.
Hast du dieses also armin von csu ne.
Ne ich glaube nicht.
Das ist ungefähr genauso also ne das ist ein kleines bisschen peinliche als du dir das vorstellen.
Gott weißt du etwa was ich mir vorstelle oder.
Amen von csu die haben sich da irgendwie so also auf alten bildern hat er einfach einen schönen schwiegermutter haarschnitt und und 'ne.
Ach ja oh ja das habe ich gesehen.
Haben sie die brille weggenommen und jahre in in wasserstoff-peroxid getunkt und da gehe reingemacht und jetzt wusste er da irgendwie muss er dann irgendwie greta ne total,
tal geknackt und jetzt natürlich die cdu gesagt okay wenn ihr eine reaktion habt ne halt mal mein meine maßkrug ja wir haben auch was und zwar,
wir haben jetzt spinnt doktoren für die sozialen medien ja und sie möchten.
In der berliner cdu zentrale neue kommunikations- politische arbeitsabläufe setzen und da gibt's auch ein konzept mit dem neu punkt startpunkt,
ja das hat irgendwie vierundfünfzig seiten da möchten sie schneller auf ereignisse im internet reagieren können mit einem krisen radar und einem news room und ein team,
von etwa einem dutzend mitarbeiterin und die sollen rund um die uhr sehen wenn sich was zusammenbraut.
Ja und die haben ja vor kurzem schon auf twitter irgendwie jobs angeboten.
Für personen die sich mit diesem internet auskennen das waren wohl die leute die sie da suchen ja oder,
haben sie eine vierundfünfzig seiten strategie die warnhinweise in drei stufen vorsieht beobachten vorbereiten.
Eingreifen.
Und die müssen dann regelmäßige berichte erstatten zu den fragen worüber debattiert das netz worüber unsere wähler und wo spielen wir eine rolle.
Ja und das muss einheitlich und zusammenfassend cross medial kommuniziert werden um zielgruppe unspezifisch kanal gerecht und zweck bestimmt.
Auf dem punkt zu landen und.
Ein krisen handbuch haben sie auch ja das wird erarbeitet ja wo sie dann.
Also die cdu zentrale wird in krisen handtuch haben eine abgespeckte variante davon werden sie auch ihren landesverbänden zur verfügung stellen ja,
wo zum beispiel die zahl der schleife zur freigabe von pressemitteilung und sonstigen,
reduziert wird damit die schneller reagieren können.
Ich freue mich also beobachten vorbereiten gott ja also.
Aber eins reiten.
Ein eingreifen also ja wo wie also.
Ich stell mir dann so vor ich stell mir dann sofort wie die wie die cdu zentrale setzen wenn wir da irgendwie auf twitter verarsche okay eingriff.
Und dann wird zurück getwittert oder was.
Ja ab heute wird zurück getwittert.
Oh mann das ist so.
Ja ich meine man man kann das jetzt gibt's verschiedenen perspektiven wie man das so beachten kann ja man könnte sagen.
Ist ja schön dass sie jetzt den diskussionen im netz aktiv folgen wollen,
na also beobachten und leute worüber reden die und so immerhin wurde ja lange zeit vorgeworfen dass sie das komplett ignorieren das tun sie jetzt nicht mehr ist ja in ordnung.
Und warum soll man nicht auch dafür eine gruppe haben die das defizit tut und nicht nur so am person wenn mal irgendein abgeordneter was mitbekommen dann auf dem klo ist und irgendwie durch twitter das kreuz alles halt schon so leute gibt die sagen so hier nochmal.
Der kommentar von söder okay csu von irgendjemand von der cdu,
auf der csu und es geht nur für die cdu bei kriegen sie wahrscheinlich nach wie vor nichts mehr.
So da braut sich was zusammen da sollten wir mal eine position finden.
Bisher ist ja erstmal nicht falsch bloß wo es wirklich lustig werden wird denke ich mal ist halt dieser bereich des eingreifens wo sie dann sozusagen oh jetzt müssen wir aber auch drauf reagieren,
nicht wo wir machen vielleicht denken wir nehmen das feedback mal als solches und vielleicht sogar immer unsere politik anpassen sollen nee wir müssen jetzt sozusagen.
In den medialen kampf,
und irgendwas raushauen um dem zu begegnen ich meine so macht das trump braucht ne also es ist sozusagen also müssen wir halt gegen nachrichten streuen dieses irgendwie anders darstellen.
Das ist ja sollte unterstellung von mir ne also ich sag nur es gibt verschiedene aspekte wie man darauf schauen.
Ein unternehmen da würde,
ein unternehmen das irgendwie social media ausgesetzt ich glaube nicht dass es größere unternehmen gibt die
zwanzig neunzehn noch keine er doch gibt's wahrscheinlich aber die meisten haben durchaus,
irgendwie eine strategie oder auch eine eskalation möglichkeit für social media und ich würde auch davon ausgehen.
Dass die cdu das hat.
Gehabt hat und was das entscheidende ist warum das so erbärmlich ist ist das denen das überhaupt nichts gebracht hätte in diesem resort thema.
Denn.
Krisen kommunikation in den sozialen medien geht halt weiß ich wenn du irgendwie einen shitstorm an der barkas und irgendwie sage ich mal,
dinge korrigieren kannst ja weil wenn ihr oder oder sagen kannst das ist nicht so schlimm oder wir kümmern uns drum oder so oder diese behauptung die da getätigt wird die stimmt nicht hier ist der beweis tweet,
ja aber das das wären ja alles die hätten ja jetzt nicht durch eine schnellere reaktion auf resort irgendetwas,
dazu sagen können er werden nicht schnell genug reagiert nein ihr habt einfach zwanzig dreißig,
vierzig sechzig jahre lang scheiß politik gemacht und dann hat's euch mal kalt erwischt weil jemand euren scheiß der letzten jahre mal kurz aufbereitet hat in einem annähernd einstündigen video,
so da kann man jetzt nicht sagen oh wir haben ne wir brauchen aber jetzt hier wir müssen.
Da gab's noch nichts zu beobachten.
Genau da gab's auch nix.
Wenn sie ja nichts vorbereiten können und bitte eingriff ich meine da kannst du auch nicht mehr eingreifen,
ne aber ich glaube darum geht's ja auch vielleicht gar nicht meine jetzt die berichterstattung die machst du ja leute nach risiko haben sie dann endlich mal gemerkt wie schlecht sie dastehen ne weil da waren halt einfach mal die hosen ganz unten.
Es gibt ja auch noch andere konstellationen wo man durchaus darauf reagieren kann meine generell so der debatte zu folgen um mal zu schauen so hier unser klima paket kommt irgendwie nicht so gut an,
aber es hat mir auch schon vorher sagen können.
Vor allem hat es also gerade dieses video warum ich das so witzig finde ist das hat relativ wenig mit social media zu tun was er da gemacht hat.
So ist es hat sich durch social media verbreitet aber jemand wie jan böhmermann hätte diese inhalte wenn er motiviert gewesen wäre ähnlich mit seiner redaktion aufbereiten verbreiten können ja die.
Und dann wäre das auch viral gegangen das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie,
es gab jetzt nicht irgendwie weißt du was ich meine also es ist irgendwie so.
Ja klar kommt polizistin sohn schieb linie sicherheitspolitik liegt so rechts rein ja und dann war 's das.
Oder und das das und das ist halt.
Die haben halt das problem nicht erkannt,
also ganz offensichtlich nicht weil sie das problem,
öl draufgießen mit ihrem csu gut dass es jetzt csu und das ist jetzt cdu aber es also diese hilflosigkeit ist wirklich faszinierend,
faszinierend.
Da hilft auch echt nur eins verjüngt euch und ja bei arbeiten arbeiten aber nicht mit solchen jungen reisen äh wie den am tor.
Greiz.
Na ja ich werde jetzt schon aus wie fünfzig.
Benjamin button.
Wird immer wird jetzt immer jünger.
Philipp.
Das heißt am ende werden unsere kinder reagier regiert das wollen wir doch mal.
Ja ja benjamin button.
Okay also der der körper ist auf jeden fall auch freuen ich bin ja mal gespannt man kann auf jeden fall jetzt regelmäßig einfach mal fragen in welcher phase sich die cdu befindet ob sie noch beim beobachten sind oder schon beim eingriff.
Und ja.
Tja müssen sich auf jeden fall warm anziehen.
Ja also wenn sie so weitermachen dann auf jeden fall.
Neue klamotten kaufen aber mit mit einkaufen.
Jo damit werden wir glaube ich am ende der sendung.
Du machst das einfach leute wir haben jetzt nicht so viel zu erzählen also jetzt nicht mehr ja tschüss ne bis nächste woche.
Aux